droht uns ein super flair ein
sonnensturm der plasmawolke in richtung
erde jagd und das weltweite stromnetz
extrem beschädigt und unsere gesamte
telekommunikation bedroht das hätte
fatale folgen beispielsweise für die
weltwirtschaft ein japanisches
astronomie team hat jetzt herausgefunden
dass auch sonnenähnliche sterne
besonders extreme stürme sogenannte
super plus produzieren können hundert
bis tausendmal stärker als alles was wir
bisher erlebt haben und das schon
relativ bald klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen der sonnensturm von 1859 ging
in die geschichte ein
die ausgestoßene materie von mehreren
starken sonneneruptionen erreichte nach
etwa 17 stunden die erde und zwar mit
einer geschwindigkeit von mehr als 2000
kilometern pro sekunde stark stumme
zerstörten telegrafen leitungen und das
gesamte netz das gerade erst installiert
worden war wurde enorm beschädigt
forschungsteams weltweit sind mit
hochdruck dabei mehr details über
sonneneruption zu erfahren klar ist bei
solch einem ausflug wird plasma ins all
geschleuderten dabei wird energiereiche
strahlung frei so genannte flairs das
problem solche ausbrüche sind nicht
wirklich vorauszusehen doch die signale
einer sonneneruption erreichen die erde
innerhalb von etwa acht minuten
japanische wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben jetzt neue super
spannende erkenntnisse zum thema
gesammelt das team hatte 43
sonnenähnliche sterne bei denen zuvor
bereits superflex beobachtet werden
konnten mit dem goya weltraumteleskop
und einem amerikanischen teleskop
genauer ins visier genommen bei ihrer
analyse ging es darum wie oft superflex
vorkommen wie alt die jeweiligen sterne
sind und ob es sich bei ihnen
tatsächlich um einzelsterne handelt und
das ergebnis ist überraschend denn der
japanischen studie zufolge kommen super
fans eben nicht nur bei jungen sterne
vor stattdessen ist dieses phänomen auch
bei älteren langsam rotierenden sternen
zu beobachten sprich der sonne
allerdings sind die strahlen ausbrüche
dann nicht ganz so gewaltig junge sterne
aber produzieren super fließen mit einer
energie von achtung 100
milliarden petajoule wir sind also
besonders extreme strahlen ausbrüche zu
beobachten schon frühere beobachtungen
mit weltraumteleskopen hatten gezeigt
dass schnell rotierende junge sterne
gigantische strahlen ausbrüche
produzieren können die aktuelle studie
bestätigt dass nun die analyse der
japanischen fachleute zeigt aber auch
dass extreme superflat bei der sonne und
bei anderen sonnenähnlichen sternen
vorkommen aber eher selten dazu heißt es
in der studie
bei sonnenähnlichen sternen in alter von
rund 4,6 milliarden jahren würden
superflat dieser stärke etwa alle zwei
bis dreitausend jahre einmal auftritt
auch wenn unsere sonne sich demnach
meistens nicht wirklich extrem verhält
ist ihr magnetfeld anders als bislang
angenommen also keineswegs zu schwach um
gewaltige super flairs zu produzieren
entwarnung für das leben auf der erde
bedeutet das keineswegs im gegenteil
denn auch flairs mit einer lediglich 100
bis 1000 fachen stärke gewöhnlicher
flairs können fatale folgen für unsere
zivilisation mit sich bringen im
angesicht dieser bedrohung sind wir
allerdings äußerst schlecht auf einen
möglichen nächsten sonnensturm
vorbereitet forschungsteams weltweit
versuchen also notgedrungen über
statistiken und simulationen
herauszukristallisieren wie häufig und
wie schlimm sonnenstürme uns in der
erdgeschichte bereits getroffen haben
radioaktive baumringe legen nahe dass in
den jahren 675 und 994 gigantische
teilchen wellen über die erde hinweg
gefegt sein müssen auch die analyse des
lichts von knapp 150000 sonnenähnlichen
stern konnte der wissenschaftswelt etwas
über die häufigkeit solcher stürme
verraten eine weitere gewaltige strahlen
dusche aus dem all bekamen die erde wohl
auch vor knapp 7500 jahren ab das
japanische forschungsteam geht mit
großer sicherheit davon aus dass es sich
damals um extreme sonnenfleck gehandelt
haben muss doch wie groß ist das risiko
dass sich ein solches ereignis in naher
zukunft wiederholt laut des japanischen
astronomen sutter note so ist der
nächste super fair der sonne nur eine
frage der zeit dass besteht durchaus die
möglichkeit das wäre ein solches
ereignis in den nächsten 100 jahren oder
so erleben werden noch mal zum
mitschreiben in den nächsten 100 jahren
könnte und so ein super sonnensturm
erreichen und
um netze telekommunikation und so weiter
und so fort ernsthaft beschädigen
es könnte wochen und monate dauern bis
alles wieder funktioniert die
weltwirtschaft könnte großen schaden
nehmen aktienkurse einbrechen banken
pleitegehen es könnte absolut
dramatische folgen haben
diese erkenntnisse verdeutlichen noch
einmal wie dringend notwendig es ist
dass wir die prozesse auf der sonne
besser verstehen denn nur so können wir
sie auch irgendwann einmal vorhersagen
zwar sehen teleskope und erdmann
satelliten den ausbruch der sonne
doch dann muss auch eingeschätzt werden
wie stark er ausfallen wird und ob er
die erde überhaupt treffen wird erst 20
minuten bevor der sturm die erde
erreicht ist dann auch klar in welche
richtung sein magnetfeld zeigen wird und
das ist entscheidend dafür wie gut er
das irdische magnetfeld durchdringen
wird derzeit spielen wir quasi
russisches roulette mit der sonne die
europäische raumsonde solar orbiter die
im februar 2020 aufbrechen soll wird uns
mehr informationen liefern aber dann
müssen wir auch konsequenzen ziehen und
die strom- und kommunikationsnetze gegen
solche solar superstürmer sicher machen
wie groß ist eigentlich die sonne
größenvergleich sonnensystem coolen
video bei astro comics tv hier anklicken
anschauen und auf jeden fall abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran